bonjour à toutes et à tous je suis dit
oh je joue tir il l'agent de la cyber
histoire dans la saison 1 de taille
noirci qu'un petit rôle de parent man
mémorable que c'est et il s'avère qu'une
saison 2 est en cours de préparation et
je suis tout excité à ce fait plus
sérieusement c'est une saison 2 que
j'attends avec impatience qui va être
énorme more fun et très ambitieuse mais
c'est elle tellement j'ai lu le script
je sais pas combien de fois et ça me
donne vraiment très très envie d'agir il
ya beaucoup de d'humour là de l'action
il ya des retournements de situation il
ya des nouveaux personnages qui sont
super il ya vraiment de tout et je pense
qu'on peut faire un truc vraiment
vraiment stylé il ya aussi des cas mais
au un peu gratuit j'espère qu'il y en
aura encore plus d'ailleurs que la
campanule a été lancé il ya déjà jure
jours plusieurs semaines et il s'agirait
de donner des sous s'il vous plaît si
vous ne faites pas pour la prof est le
pour la si belle histoire qui a besoin
de fonds pour améliorer c'est bon
travailler en temps c'est important
parce qu'il ya beaucoup trop de bugs
bain des anachronismes ça super donc
voilà je suis super enjoué à l'idée que
que ça puisse se faire
j'espère vraiment qu'on va atteindre le
plafond le bled tous les paliers de la
compagnie du pouvoir faire plein de
trucs avoir d'effets spéciaux pour
l'avoir ce tournage de qualité parce que
derrière fort belle fille club sera peu
à larache
on va pas se mentir et puis non j'ai
hâte aussi de retrouver toute l'équipe
tout le monde parce qu'il y avait
vraiment une super ambiance sûr c'est
vraiment super des mezzés je suis dit un
peu déçu que cyrille godefroy ne
reviennent pas spoiler mais voilà en
tout cas sachez qu'il ya le temps à la
description
voilà il serait fort agréable de votre
part de lâcher en petit don contrepartie
nous même si c'est un euro 5 euros 10
euros 1000 cbr 1000 si vous pouvez fait
que moi je me suis pauvre mais je viens
du futur mais on n'a pas la même bonnet
fait dépasser au cyber euros du coup je
peux pas façon ma carte
car il n'existe pas de carte je peux
faire ça que par paiement avec toi enfin
bref j'espère que vous êtes aussi excité
que moi à l'idée de cette prochaine
saison
même de ces prochaines saisons s'est on
jamais et j'espère que qu'on va pouvoir
vous satisfaire avec cette nouvelle
saison
tu as lu c'était guillaud